oh all
right hi I'm Johnny G the Columbus Blue
Jackets mat bers from the Seattle crack
Seth Jones with the Chicago Blackhawks Conor B to
the Chicago Blackhawks Matt baly with the
Minnesota Wild Mark Stone from the Vegas
nights and I'm going to break stuff we're
here to Break Stuff let's go break some
stuff are these going to break with a wrist
shot might have to take a slap shot what am
I trying to do just break them hit them both
I'll probably miss him though I don't have the
hardest shot so we'll see if anything breaks
never done anything like this but uh see what
happens
that's a lot ofing eggs good good and action heads
up
whoops I didn't hit anything kind of
embarrassing this is turning into
quite a mess that's so good that was
nice I like that that was nice still a lot of them
standing I don't even think I broke that
one when you see it explode definitely
makes you feel pretty good if you need
to relieve some stress maybe that's
a great thing for hockey players to
do made a pretty big mess but it was
fun